what are the top three worst devil Foods  in one piece and number three we have a  devil fruit that no one remembers for a  good reason one of whitebeard's allies  had the power to turn into a caterpillar  now we've seen some cool Buck  transformation in one piece but this  isn't one of them and we really wish  that we could forget the number two  worst devil food as well in the  Colosseum on dressrosa there's a fighter  named Kelly Funk who has the jacket  jacket food which lets someone unzip you  and wear you like a jacket this fruit is  less helpful and more just gross and the  number one worst devil fruit was eaten  by a character no one expected Chopper  because his human human devil fruit is  the worst one in the entire series now I  guess it was useful when a reindeer ate  it but since it just turns you into a  regular human we can only imagine how  bad and useless it would be if a regular  human ate it